We figured out this equation in the last lesson and in the previous quiz by
finding a pattern in this data right here that relates n to d. But in order to
find patterns as easily as possible, we need to see the connection between data
like we have in the table, mathematical descriptions like our equation right
here, and to add to our list, visual representations, or graphs. For the
situation we're dealing with, a graph might look something like this, but how do
we make this? Well, we start by plotting points. Each row of data in our chart
right here is a pair of numbers, one for d and one for n, and we plot those
pairs of numbers on our graph. For the first point I would graph, I have the
numbers one and 23. So if we're on our coordinate plane here, on the d-axis
which is the horizontal one right here. I'd start at zero and move over one, and
then, move up 23 on the n-axis, which is the vertical one. I could do the same
thing for 2, 46. I count over from zero in the positive direction, two slots,
one, two, and then up, 46.